bella
[Musica]
è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che sono
video sono fa vigenti e sabato e quindi
all away prima di cominciare ragazzi
come al solito è una frase che faccio da
tipo 27 anni come cazzo ha fatto a
dimenticarmi prima dell'alzheimer
prima di cominciare agazzi cosa sente di
partire con la fan art e la settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da
una persona un po diversa che wayne
sarthe che appare vale sempre ai ragazzi
però dio mio santo ma cos'è che roche
roba che rock è bellissima mi piace ma
non potete non mi fan altri che
sinceramente lissimo rega e bellissimi
veramente incredibile
e veramente incredibile che sia cioè non
ci posso credere che non ci posso
credere
[Musica]
ho sbagliato la mira solo mi sono lavato
per falsa cagata prova crearsi passando
le news o una news incredi vinto la
prossima settimana o coperto già di
video però sarò via perché devo partire
per andare in un posto dove non sono
veramente mai stato c'è una cosa
completamente nuova
vado a los angeles tanto perché tanto
ormai come andare dal lattaio vado
veramente los angels perché c'è lately
freni che sarebbe la fiera dei
videogames più grande al mondo che la
fanno a los angeles
a questo punto ragazzi faccio che
trasferirmi a los angeles e ogni tanto
vengo in italia ogni tanto però è
concluso con le news e vive di passare
agli eventi la settimana che la stessa
settimana siccome devo partire ho
cercato di passarla più che altro con
gli amici ho fatto venire a casa mia uno
dei miei migliori amici che et altro era
uno dei ragazzi con i quali ho iniziato
a fare video su youtube che ahi ahi
puffo che bel nickname scherzando luca
mi piace e fa ce lo sai che mi piace e
se abbiamo fatto una sezione video un po
la human safari una cosa tipo che una
roba che abbiamo fatto mentre giravamo
per milano ed è abbastanza carino quindi
non lo metto perché secondo me merita
[Musica]
marika
avevo un pò bevuto e non vedevo le cose
tipo cose così tanta roba strana ragazza
questi giorni ho visto una la più bella
foto di instagram che io abbia mai visto
su di me c'è è assurda non so chi abbia
scattata ma c'è allora guardate la mia
faccia di matti può non toccare mio
unicorno ti stupro la famiglia chiunque
abbia fatto questa cosa ha vinto
basta non c'è dubbio quindi ragazzi
detto questo dire che possa passare da
fare risponde la prima quando arriverà
elena arrossati favi fai un prank a una
persona a casa premetto di aver fatto
questa cosa è successo allora questo è
il break
[Musica]
e stato bello maria massa fa viva vi
risponde per me l'ha imposto lista
risponde in modo insensato a dei
commenti random che gliela magistrale
così tanto coraggio perché non ti metti
un petto su un ragno non è il ragno sul
petto un petto su ragni come quella roba
dei peli sotto le ascelle noi o le
ascelle sotto i pali al contrario è così
fatto coraggio perché non ti metti sul
petto un ragno e dopo tu lo mangi perchè
sono allergico al che c'ha pensi
tigrotto il 22 giugno viene a vedere il
papa torino ti prego no e il 22 giugno
il papa viene a vedere fa vj a torino
non mio che è contrario io mi sto
facendo lo shatush fucsia dalla
parrucchiera
ma la palla è davvero autografata da
michael jordan realtà mi sono sbagliato
non era michael jordan maira magic
johnson comunque sia è autografata
davvero da magic johnson semplicemente
la palla però non è mia ma del
proprietario della casa quindi cioè non
è che sono dato io da magic johnson a
farmi fa lotta ora fa quindi ma
[ __ ] bravi risponde esiste un
altro modo per evocare un demone se vuoi
provare devi metterti davanti allo
specchio a mezzanotte e dire tre volte
bloody mary ad alta voce vedrai cosa
fare
va bene
[Musica]
lodi mary rosy mery nodi veri e seri
caso sto dormendo si dorme qui [ __ ]
cavi quale gioca innanzitutto i cavi
sono quelli dell'alta tensione però io
sono fa mica vi il quale collegio che
più strano che tu abbia mai fatto in
assoluto ok è quello è un uomo sì quella
è pv quella è un uomo e con le pp.aa
ok sì credo che sia assassin's creed e
quindi ragazzi concluso vivido spero che
vi si aprano cazzola fa mi domando mi ha
ricordato grazie a dio ho rischiato il
linciaggio quindi ragazzi che ho fatto
colletto un casino di storie paranormali
che mi avete scritto nello scorso blog
con affari domanda infatti non so se si
vede dall occhiaie ma non sto dormendo
un cazzo e cosa vorreste che io facessi
nel prossimo cazzeggio time visto che
ieri ha fatto la reaction ai video di
cordi e se non l'avete visto ragazzi
potete cliccare qui
poi devi sapere che cosa vorreste nel
prossimo episodio il ragazzo concluso
che i video come sento se vi è piaciuto
lasciato momento mi piace lasciate mi
piace oppure un falli già incassato
potrebbe apparire di notte a urlare
davanti ai vostri specchi susseguirsi di
siete civica 1 passioni ei ragazzi